tu es sorti quand déjà de prison et une
semaine
qui suit va faire un an pour l'état vit
là je vais faire un peu un terrible sur
le col roulé noir tu le vois au [ __ ]
quoi
sylvie
qu'il est le troisième en disant tu l'a
prévenu aussi ou pas c'est une prison
c'est un club de rencontres ce site à
savoir où tu es complètement folle tu
vas y c'est quoi cette fois ci ses
smartphones du caviar 3000 euros qui
n'ont pas ce que tu dis oui un peu nous
fait sa famille
il faut embrasser chiisme et si on en
plein centre ville avec what a payé ça
s'est trouvé un flingue dans sa poche
tout à l'heure
ce type est dangereux et moment depuis
des lustres gabet heureuse
[Musique]
c'est que je crois de faire descendre la
journée si je voulais ah non tu peux pas
parce que tu aimes le maire je te donne
la moitié tout fait avec moi
[Musique]
ils arrivent tous les soirs là trois
heures précises sur le parking mais ce
soit toujours la même table comme ça il
a un oeil sur son camion pompe sa
nouvelle c4 à 40 minutes son frère 10 15
de plus pourquoi n'aurait il pas le
chauffeur non c'est clair et net
wayne rooney en train de fabriquer mon
camion
[Musique]
michel
tu as fait un truc que jamais jamais
droit du feu a touché abeilles
c'est une honte
[Musique]
parce que j'en pense non ouais s'il te
plaît parce que ça peut être d'une
violence extrême un scola dire quelle
belle pantalon